whole presentation again but i can show
the plans if needed during the
discussion
it's considered that the proposal will
not result in detrimental harm to the
immunity of neighbouring occupiers
parking or immunity space
the proposal will also preserve the
character and appearance of the site the
conservation area and the listed
building it's therefore recommended for
approval thank you chairman
thank you stay with us
can i say that we have a member of the
public who wishes to speak
joe windsor
thank you mr chairman uh can i just
remind you that you have uh uh two
minutes two minutes thank you
i'd like to start with two facts
the first is that a company has
purchased a grade two star listed
building and then immediately gone about
changing its external appearance making
significant changes
including demolishing what is described
in the report as an established part of
the street scene i care because i look
out over it
the second fact is that 85
of respondents including neighbors have
objected to what is proposed
you need to work very hard to build that
level of consensus on a topic
clearly there is anger and concern why
in short there are four reasons
first many agree with this statement in
the conservation area management plan
that silver street is quote in many ways
close to perfection in appearance
they're therefore shocked that a company
with a registered office in devon can
just come in and change that appearance
imposing its aesthetic preferences
on those who live there
second
they believe the impact that ships will
have on neighbouring properties has been
underestimated particularly in terms of
the potential for noise from the
proposed ventilation units and on the
yet undetailed external extractor usage
it is true that the condition has been
imposed or will be imposed or is
recommended to be in relation to those
units
but anyone who has tried to sleep close
to one at night will know exactly how
loud they are
third there is a disagreement with the
view that the creation of a new
galvanized steel staircase will
is consistent with the rest of the
building
put simply whatever design refinements
are applied an additional steel
staircase will stick out like a sole
thumb
finally they disagree with the
conclusion that the proposal will
preserve the character of the listed
buildings within the surrounding area
aspects of the proposal given that we
are talking about a grade 2 listed
building are being viewed with concern
as an effective green light for wider
change those are the concerns thank you
mr winter
okay members before i open the debate
can i just first of all remind
members that this was debated
in some dent depth at the previous
meeting and a site visit was proposed
and carried out on the 16th of august
and can i just remind members that we're
looking at an application
for
restoration and alterations only thank
you so can i now
open for members debate please
so cancel three
yes thank you chairman there are a
number of things i want to say on this
one first of all um
i want to thank the officer for
arranging the site visit
i and others who participated found it
extremely useful helpful
in clarifying
many of the
aspects of this complex proposal
and i feel much more
well informed about that
the
restoration is uh to be commended and
i hope the
conservation officer will continue to be
involved
as things progress
because obviously it's going to be
altered with the um
once it's
made good although i i do wonder why so
much is taking place without i
understand the previous planning
permission um
i
think the changes to fenestration and
disposing of some of the late 20th
century um
fenestration is certainly an improvement
and
similarly
the proposal at the rear forward
the canopy area
i have
two
two qualms about this
and
first of all um on parking
we know that um
there are two spaces and these are not
really enough even under our direct
conditions for a five-bedroom place let
alone a seven one which is wars
um
and um i would be concerned that um
to prevent
further parking
taking place
in the garden area
behind and i don't know whether that it
perhaps is
something that can be covered by a
condition
um the
second thing that concerns the changes
to the rear 18th century range
and the
conversion from
to reduce to three bedrooms
on a separate corridor where this
additional
staircase is proposed
um
i
i do wonder that with um
the additional staircase coming from the
kitchen area and the
upstairs rooms um
uh with a
what i think it says as a protected
corridor this would effectively create
almost an annex
in the building
and again i wonder whether a condition
can be um
placed to ensure that the place remains
as a integrated
single residence
the
more important
considerations um
concern
the
the sellers in particular
i'm not convinced that these should be
used as public rooms and as a
habitable area
um they are very simple
um sellers dug in them in the earth
for a particular purpose at a particular
time
and i think the emphasis there has to be
on conservation and if there are certain
um things that have to be done in for
conservation purposes
all well and good but i i think
trying to
modernize them or make them into
usable
residential space would involve too much
damage to the
fabric of the cellar area
partly because obviously this uh
additional staircase down through the
through the um the brick um
uh ceiling of the archway of the
cellar
and my other um
uh what we said caveat is on the carport
um
which is part of the historic
development of the building it's over
100 years old and it's part of the
historical growth of
of the property
in all its many uses
um i think
removing it would affect the street
scene for two reasons
firstly
um its removal would rather expose more
the the modern bungalow
uh that is nearby next door
um and as it stands it actually prevents
a sort of
slight visual barrier
down the street to that
bungalow and
should say
more of a gentle finish
or transition from
for silver street to the modern premises
further down
um
and i think the
mention in the documentation of
possibly opening up glimpses of the
vicarage um
is is very small compensation
um so on those i
i i think
i have strong reservations
thank you chairman thank you
councilwoman but i don't believe that
you have no questions that um
in there or
can any of the officers comment on what
was just said
okay
thank you
any comment from the officers please
do chairman in relation to parking the
development
proposed
doesn't result in
an increase in level of demand for car
parking so that wouldn't be material
to the application
and i um the similarity
confirmed that i'd be correct with the
uh
um
that'd be similar with the other
condition in relation to it the
application is still a dwelling there is
no subdivision as part of it um so i'm
not sure that would be in the proper
condition either
okay
thank you
you want to come back on count this way
no
anyone else has a
i'm just questioning um
if
there is a
start to parking additional vehicles in
the garden is there
um is there a planning control on that
particular conservation area
uh for you chairman um
a condition to remove permitted
development rights to
um install hard standing in the garden
wouldn't meet the six tests uh it
wouldn't be relevant to the development
um or reasonable proportionate and so i
it wouldn't um be reasonable to include
that condition
thank you okay thank you
thank you mr chairman um a couple of
questions um louise this application is
for a dwelling house and for nothing
else is it so where councillor swain
said about um
eating or another room in the cellar
this is that wasn't part of this
palladium permission and if they wanted
change of use they've got to come back
for another
planning application
i have reservations about the staircase
as i've said to you i have reservations
about it going through the roof and can
we be sure that the
cellar roof will be structurally stable
by putting another staircase in
and also i have reservations about the
steel door
which would be in place in the cellar
causing
basically a vacuum as such where they
put the air conditioning in one part the
cellar
and the other part remains damp and they
said that they're they do have standing
water in that part
so they're my two main reservations
about
what is going on with this the other
thing is under one of our conditions
which is 5.4.2
it says that there will be um five
bedrooms a four bedroom
dwelling should have three car parking
spaces but we've ignored that
chairman and in relation to parking
there's already only
two parking spaces so there's already a
shortfall of one space and there will
remain a shortfall of one space
um so that will remain consistent we
can't force them to create another space
um on the site
in relation to the structural
aspects um no objections have been
raised in terms of
that and that would be
more down to building regulations um
however
we could include a condition and to get
them to submit a structural report which
i believe they have undertaken but it
hasn't been as submitted as part of the
application and so that could be
conditioned if that's required
um in relation to the steel door and the
stairs um again we don't have any
objections to that neither does the
conservation officer or historic england
um but if you wanted to impose a
condition to require
additional details and
sort of alternative materials and that
would be reasonable to do so
thank you can i ask thank you did you
want to go back on that at all just one
question um
has historic england actually visited
the site
chairman i don't i don't believe that
they do site visits for this type of
application
can i ask a couple of questions um first
of all the second staircase in the
cellar is a health and safety
requirement isn't it is that correct
if the one at the stab at the far end
i think that's they've said that's why
they want it but that hasn't that's not
sort of a planning consideration for us
okay and also
the stairwell and the doors could be a
combination of metal and wood
you chairman they could be they could be
any material
right because there was
there was
concern about the cellar door being
metal and the moisture i think was it
was the dampness getting through
but if it was wood of course it will rot
that's a possibility yeah so okay thank
you um
cancer
seance
thank you chairman um i just have a few
concerns
the
staircase that's going up from the
ground floor in the kitchen area
i just need a little bit of
clarity there
um
if if if i can um it's it's when we were
there on the site visit it said it was
going up from the kitchen
but in the text tonight that we have in
front of us it talks about rooms next to
the kitchen being arranged to provide
the staircase
now
it may be um you know sort of nitpicking
here but i think
you know a
planning application of this um
importance should you know have clarity
on those
uh on those things um i also have
concerns which which have been raised
about the um staircase going up from the
seller
someone went to um great length to
explain why this sloping roof above the
carport was being taken away to expose
an old piece of wall
i get that that's that's fine um
but they did say that none of the
brickwork to that carport was going to
be touched when we had the site visit
i don't know if any other councillors
remember that um
that we were told um
but
but we were being um talked to by the
owner and the architect you know kind of
spoken at by them um and it was one of
those um instances that that assurance
and was put before us
ms staplehurst quite rightly um
said that really it should only have
been mr house and talking about the site
visit and not these two other people
that were there
but however you know she couldn't put
gags on them and totally stop them
talking as we appreciate
and you know when they were
you know coming at us with these things
so i'd like to take up that point about
um not having the brickwork taken down
on the carport i understand that the
doors at the front are to remain
but i can see no point at having that
red brickwork taken down
at all and we had an assurance at the
site visit that it wouldn't be
um if i can go on to the windows now
i i do feel rather happier about the
windows that i did before we had the
site visit chairman
um because um
they like the sash windows um
the people who are doing this
quite rightly so but there are some more
modern windows there um and it was
stated and and and mr halsen also said
um that other windows were going to be
put in to sort of match those um sash
windows i hope i'm right in what i'm
saying there is stable earth
um so i'm very happy about that now
because originally i thought well you
know different windows show different
stages of of the building um but but if
it is to um
you know be
a bit more sort of consistent with um
certain ages of the building um then if
if a couple of sash windows are going to
remain particularly on the first floor
of the northern um
wall um then i'm i'm quite happy with
that i mean i understand that old
windows will need some attention and
they can't maybe just leave them solely
as they are um you know they might have
to do a little bit of woodwork on them
you know
as or not all old things but if the you
know the windows are going to be sash
windows to match those um then i i'm i
think that that is um
quite acceptable chairman thank you um
and
i just i'm going to bring this up on any
development now about gas boilers i
understand a gas boiler is proposed to
put in and i know gas boilers i've been
told by mr lee that they can't um stop
developers um are not obliged to um
they they can put gas boilers in until
2023 um they're not obliged to but you
know um
they they probably will so i would just
like to bring that up chairman because
these gas boilers um
last at least 10 years and we are um you
know hoping to be environmentally sound
as a
as a council
and so i would just like to make that
point thank you very much german thank
you council
councillor bill
thank you chairman i'm also worried
about the windows
um
you know if they're going to change
windows then make it so that they're all
uniform
preferably to the oldest ones because it
is in a conservation area the other
thing i'm worried about
is this staircase that they're going to
put into the seller
why would a domestic property need to
end exits
only a business would demand that
and if you read
the um
notice that was up on the front of the
house
but was taken down before we viewed
they're talking about up to 30 people
being there
you know it's it it smacks of something
else i know
that
doing it as a
i can't remember what it's called
renting the place out or whatever but
you've got the car parking spaces enough
for two
and so we're short there so if you're
gonna have up to eight people there
where are they gonna park
i mean
that staircase is totally gonna ruin the
sellers the part they're gonna be using
and they are damaging historical
i mean really old stuff
so yeah i've got real problems with it
i mean i'd like to see it done up
but i think they're trying to
to basically modernize it
which i can't see that you can do on a
grade two listed building
and as for historic england or whatever
they're called not visiting the site i
just cannot believe that
with a property of this importance it's
a nonsense
thank you council bill is any comments
from
planning officers at all on that you
know
now
any further
i can't hope sorry i couldn't see you
thank you
thank you chairman
um i won't go over the ground that's
already been covered and we've discussed
this last time we met in
in great detail but
my main concern is this is an
application for a dwelling house
and
the advertising from the company that
owned the building
tells us otherwise you know they're
developing this to rent out
the talk on their website
that it will become a luxury holiday
home to rent out five bedrooms including
four on together a formal dining area
for up to 16 guests
and a seller with a sound system that
will accommodate at least 30 people
an ideal venue for wedding receptions
christenings anniversaries and similar
events
now to me
that in itself should ring bells and uh
the problem is
we talk about uh
it's
t2 has been covered
but then t2 also talks about
providing enough car parking
according to any development that is
required in the
area
so
yeah
that's my only concern
thank you councillor uh humbler but i
can only repeat what i said earlier yes
we've got the application in front of us
which is for restoration um only and not
for any planned use of a dwelling house
um
mr lee
thank you chairman promoting me um
just a couple of points have been raised
and i think i just need a couple of
points and i will
not necessarily wax liverpool about what
i was going to take for future discovery
but one of the first things i would like
to say is obviously that the
site visit that occurred that members
attended was part of the planning
committee and it should be considered
and dealt with like that
so any comments that were made by any
members of public present or in the
vicinity of that
uh should be given similar weight to if
it was the two minutes at the beginning
of the
committee so although i'm just conscious
obviously there may well have been a lot
of information
provided but that should be given
appropriate weight in the termination of
this application as in it hasn't been
formally submitted as part of the
application it hasn't been assessed by
officers etc so members need to be
conscious of that obviously you know
there's
councilmembers were saying so we can't
gag members of public but you know
obviously we shouldn't actually be they
shouldn't really have been entering into
baseball so there's only so much we can
physically do and we understand that but
just advise members to give weight
appropriately to anything that was
discussed then and just to echo what the
chairman said you know an application
has to be determined on its merits what
we have in front of us is
in relation to a single dwelling it
you know i think we've all had
correspondence where there's indications
there may be a proposed separate use
and it's likely that would need a
separate application so
we can't determine application on uh
what we may consider maybe a future use
or a future breach of planning control
that'd be something that would need to
be interrogated and dealt with
separately you know we have in front of
us what we have in front of us members
and i'd just like to remind you all of
that thank you very much thank you
oh yes thank you
thank you mr chairman um can i ask why
so much has been done inside that
property before they got planning
permission i know that we were told that
the
work was done to expose areas so they
could look at
the older parts of the property and
to to try and excavate to see what they
could find um for the history of the
property but to take up
four floors
and to take all the plaster off the
walls upstairs it seems to be that that
was an awful lot
normally when an archaeologist does an
exploration they do a small section
but we walked into what was a building
site
and i just wondered why so much had been
done before they got planning permission
three chairman um
i don't disagree from i've been on site
percy but from what i understand you
know i wouldn't disagree that maybe more
work has been undertaken it was strictly
necessary to do things such as checking
the validity of structures etc um
while they've done that it's not
consideration for the termination
application you know as members knows
i've said it before and i'll probably
end up saying a number of times you know
the legislation allows for retrospective
applications it allows for uh
development to be regularized um
most instances obviously this would be
difficult it would be a list of
buildings so if it is development
without permission it actually would be
illegal but most instances planning
doing work without permission isn't
illegal and
the thought process behind it censoring
isn't a material consideration
determination application it is whether
or not is the work acceptable or not um
so the answer is you can ask if i don't
have the answer
thank you sherman thank you
okay is everyone
cancer
yes thank you jim just just a
couple of very brief things firstly um
there were um
well uh there was information from um
the
uh the the owners should we say or there
but it was
um as far as i could see it was purely
clarification information
which was helpful and not in any way
trying to steer things
um second point for um
mr liz um
what would it take or what is the
difference between grade 2 star and
grade 1.
does this building because of its
complicated and extensive history
merit grade 1
through your chairman um
not particularly easy question to answer
um i'll thank the member for that
um
grade one is obviously or historically
there was only grade one and grade two
and obviously grade 2 star was brought
in to elevate
the grade 2 star um
grade 1 are
quite limited um
does it merit it to be honest personally
from my knowledge i wouldn't have
thought so but to some extent
that's not my professionalism you know
it's not the lpa it's not the planners
that decide on whether or not something
warrants that level of protection so
um i wouldn't really feel comfortable
commenting other than it is grade two
star and
that has been the
classification that has been given to it
so but on whether or not it would
warrant another one i wouldn't feel
comfortable in making a professional
judgment thank you chairman
thank you
okay members um
the recommendation
is for approval so
um
you'll ask for a second for that to
start with
just for a second for that please
no
is there an alternative proposal then
country stores
i would recommend refusal of the
application because
the
harm being done to the building by going
through the cellar i think outweighs the
good of the
work that will be done
to the rest of the building
extensive and unnecessary
works to the
uh
for
that
unfortunately cancer robert you can't
vote on this i'm afraid only nor can you
cancel bill i'm afraid
because uh
only members who attended the site can
yes but then you left halfway through
and i just
understand that but you would left
the committee shall i say
check the accuracy chairman yeah for
clarity obviously the way that the
council structure is set up the council
any site visit is delivered through the
deferral from a
committee so that site visit becomes
part of the formal committee meeting so
similar to the debate in the chamber if
you were to get out and leave
even though you might have been outside
then heard it all you wouldn't be able
to vote and it's so it's the same
reasons although you may have been at
the site visit for the majority of it
the fact that you weren't there for the
entirety means that you wouldn't you
weren't at the whole committee process
but that's part of the personal issues
we have with our structure on site
visits but i'll stop there thank you
thank you
so catch it
i'll second it um chairman thank you
okay
so
do we have a
can i
say all those in favor of refusal
one two three
and abstain
so it's
refused thank you
thank you mr world
winter
obviously as always uh officers have got
the synopsis of the
reasons refusal and obviously will
add the policies et cetera you know
we're not expecting members to quote the
policies in their reasons refusal thanks
chad okay thank you
okay members we move on now to item six
on pages 41-52
can i ask
who is pleased to present the report
thank you chairman
planning permission is sought for a
replacement dwelling
this follows two previous applications
on the site um which i'll expand on in a
minute
and the only alterations between
the previous application which was
approved and the current application
are that
the ridgeline is um 300 millimeters
taller
the front projection is 200 millimeters
taller
the depth has been reduced by 0.8 meters
and the materials have changed from
render to brick to match the street
scene
so you can see the location plan showing
the site in red on the southwestern side
of acacia drive
the site plan showing the proposed
dwelling and the layout
the existing elevations and floor plans
and the proposed elevations
and the proposed floor plans
there will be three bedrooms with one at
ground floor
so level was a previous application
approved in 2019
and these are the plans for that
and then also another application
approved last year and these are the
plans for that application
so as a comparison and these the two
previous approved front elevations and
then the current proposed front
elevation and so you can see how similar
the proposal is
as mentioned earlier the only
alterations relate to the marginal
increase in roof height decrease in
depth and change of materials
there are some photographs of the site
um so
this is the application site and you can
see most of the dwellings in the street
scene are two story
and some views within the site of the
garden rear elevation and either naver
and some photos of the opposite side of
the road sort of showing the mix in
property styles
in conclusion the proposal would be very
similar to that already approved
the development is not considered to
harm the character of the area
neighboring sites amenity space or
highway safety and is therefore
recommended for approval thank you
chairman thank you
and um we have a member of the public
who would like to speak on behalf of the
agent and is that miss miss brown we
don't have two minutes
thank you mr chairman i'll be quite
brief
we've made it a little bit smaller
and a little bit taller
and we've changed what was a combination
of render and brickwork to the front to
just brickwork
um previously went through without
any
objections at all um
and the buildings on either side of it
are much taller than the proposal we've
still got
the primary rooms in the first floor are
within the volume of the roof
i just decided that the rooms would work
a little bit better if the the roof went
up another 300 ml so it's the length of
a ruler
and that's it thank you
thank you very much
members okay open for debate
first of all uh okay
catch a bill sorry yeah see you there
thank you chairman
um the only bit i'm miffed about is
actually losing a bungalow because being
a fossil myself
there's a there is a call for bungalows
seeing as the population of modernity's
getting older
fortunately we can't do anything about
that
but we have got to take into context
that it's already had
i think it was two other planning
applications that didn't have any
problems with it
it's smaller and
i know we're going to lose a bungalow
but at the end of the day it's not going
to be out of character it's going to
basically blend in with everything else
yeah thank you council bill counter
stilts
um
can i ask the question is the bungalow
or the new dwelling overlooking any
other properties like the back of the
house
of the garden
and
does it have enough land space around it
as per the ldp
through chairman and there's no
residential properties to the rear it
backs onto the bottom of other gardens
so there won't be any concerns with
overlooking and it has a very large
garden so over the 100 square meters
standard thank you
thank you cancer
thank you chairman
um yes i was um
quite concerned um about
this um before um i'm very pleased that
the um
the people
that wish to have this built instead of
the bungalow have gone to brick instead
of render i think it does fit in with
the street scene much better
also very pleased to see that they are
including solar panels um on the i think
which is the back roof um i i think i
read um so they won't necessarily be
seen from the front
um
so i'd just like to say that i'm pleased
about those um two aspects of this
chairman thank you thank you
council shawnee
council
can i ask if we could put into the
conditions to have electric charging
points
put in and any other green
infrastructure
that needs to be in place
chairman we could include in the
condition uh in relation to the sort of
parking areas um we could add that one
of the park uh one of the spaces needs
to have a fast charge point thank you
chairman
thank you
anyone else catch the bill
i'd just like to propose that we accept
the officer's recommendation
thank you
the second that dude chairman is that
with the additional condition
council bill was that with that
condition
it would be nice
because i do agree with uh counseling
shawnee that about the boilers etcetera
etcetera it would be nice to get the
there's an air cooled condenser or
something
that's going to save them a lot more
money when they do have to come off of
the boilers
so yeah i'm happy with that sorry cancer
build the condition was electric
charging points yeah i agree with that
as well
it was second
okay
all right sorry
uh
mr lee would you like to address the
committee
i watched this out a big problem thank
you
so okay um
so hands please we'll vote on it now so
for the
approval with the recommendation
and i abstain so
it's passed
thank you
thank you very much
uh mr lee would like to address the
committee please on item five i believe
yep thank you chairman um just
just an issue sort of crossed my mind um
obviously members we've debated item
five and
and obviously voted on it and my
decision but the actual application
related to both a planning application
and enlisted building consent um
and obviously we weren't specific in
relation to the vote or the debate on
that matter
what that wouldn't necessarily be a
specific issue per se if the items
clearly related to each other
the
amendment
as i see it myself is that while it
talked about changed the fabric of the
building the things that were picked out
specifically only related to internal
work so
for clarity can is it possible if we can
revisit that because
the planning application aspects would
not be
for one of that phrase worried about the
internal work because that's not
development the list of building consent
would be the only piece that would be
worried about the internal work so if
actually if the application if the
member's concerns are
in relation to the historic fabric of
the building are only about internal
members should look to actually grant
planning permission for the full
uh
aspect because that only relates to the
outside for one of a better phrase but
if the
concerns are the changes outside as well
then
that's fine but just for clarity
obviously if we can have that members
that would be helpful
i would propose that we look at the
outside of the building as well i'm not
happy with as councillor shaunicy said
we were told that the brick
was coming down on the carpool and the
the
i know that their reasons behind the
roof is coming off but
i'm not happy with that either thank you
i feel clarity that was all through the
debate so that was fine so that's why i
just wanted some points of clarity for
members just for obviously all those
matters were discussed in debate so it
was all there in the round in the
knowledge it was just that i needed
clarity for formulating the reasons
refusal specifically thank you okay
councilman did you want to say something
to that um
well yes i mean in in refusing we were
infusing both were we not the um the
application and the listed building
consent
the uh i just wanted clarity that is
correct because obviously we've had
situations before where
we've had a list of building consent and
a fall and then we've tried to refuse it
someone overlooking which wouldn't be
the listed building consent so we've had
to have these conversations before but
it's just a point of clarity so that
i'll make sure that we are making the
quick
reasons for you to go out what the
committee wanted thank you
because you can't really
distinguish structural from internal in
this particular case can we
thank you councillor
um
any other items of business six there is
none so therefore i close this meeting
at 8 16. thank you very much
[Music]